(man) THIS IS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
COME SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS‐‐
FIVE POWERFUL SELF‐MADE
INVESTORS WORTH BILLIONS.
IN THE TANK, THE SHARKS
ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY...
OKAY, I‐I'M ON THE FENCE.
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT BUSINESS.
THIS IS SO CRAZY. I CAN'T
BELIEVE... (speaks indistinctly)
OKAY, IF YOU DON'T HAVE CATS,
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
(laughs)
AND IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
I LIKE THIS PRODUCT, THE IDEA.
SO MAKE AN OFFER, HARRINGTON.
NO, WAIT JUST A MINUTE.
BUT FIRST, THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
SALES ARE GOING DOWN,
THE MARKET'S GETTING SOFT,
PRICE POINTS ARE COMING DOWN.
I WANNA SLIT MY WRIST.
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
KEVIN O'LEARY
KNOWS HOW TO MAKE MONEY.
HE STARTED A SOFTWARE BUSINESS
IN HIS BASEMENT,
WHICH HE EVENTUALLY SOLD
FOR $3.2 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN‐‐
THIS FIERY REAL ESTATE MOGUL
TURNED A $1,000 LOAN
INTO A REAL ESTATE EMPIRE
WORTH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
IN THE SHARK‐FILLED CITY
OF MANHATTAN.
KEVIN HARRINGTON
IS THE KING OF INFOMERCIALS.
HIS GENIUS MARKETING
OF PRODUCTS
HAS AMASSED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN SALES.
DAYMOND JOHN TURNED
RAGS TO RICHES
WITH HIS CLOTHING BRAND FUBU,
WHICH HAS GROSSED
OVER $6 BILLION
IN WORLDWIDE RETAIL SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC,
THE SON OF A FACTORY WORKER
TURNED TECHNOLOGY MOGUL,
SOLD HIS FIRST
INTERNET COMPANIES
FOR OVER $350 MILLION.
FIRST INTO THE SHARK TANK IS
REBECCA RESCATE
WITH A PRODUCT
SHE BELIEVES WILL HELP
CAT LOVERS EVERYWHERE.
♪♪♪
I'M REBECCA RESCATE. I LIVE
IN YARDLEY, PENNSYLVANIA,
WITH MY FAMILY
AND MY LOVING CAT SAMANTHA.
A FEW YEARS AGO,
WE WERE LIVING
IN A TINY APARTMENT
IN MANHATTAN.
THE PROBLEM WAS, AS SOON AS YOU
WALKED IN OUR FRONT DOOR,
YOU KNEW WE HAD A CAT.
YOU COULD SMELL THE LITTER BOX
NO MATTER HOW OFTEN
WE CLEANED IT.
IT STUNK UP THE PLACE.
IT'S GROSS.
EW!
IT HAD TO GO. WHEN I WAS
LOOKING FOR A SOLUTION,
I WAS LOOKING
TO JUST BUY SOMETHING
THAT COULD SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
FOR ME, AND IT DIDN'T EXIST.
SO I CREATED MY OWN,
AND CitiKitty WAS BORN.
NOW OUR HOME IS LITTER‐FREE
AND MESS‐FREE AND PERFECT.
SINCE I STARTED CitiKitty,
A LOT HAS CHANGED.
I'VE MOVED OUT TO THE SUBURBS,
I HAVE THREE KIDS...
(girl speaks indistinctly)
AND I'M LIMITED ON TIME.
I HAVE GREAT VISIONS
FOR CitiKitty.
AND I NEED HELP.
I NEED SOMEBODY THAT'S AN EXPERT
AT BRINGING A PRODUCT TO MARKET
AND GETTING IT INTO MASS RETAIL.
I WANT CAT OWNERS AROUND
THE WORLD TO BE USING IT,
AND I NEED THE SHARKS' HELP
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
♪♪♪
HI. I'M REBECCA RESCATE,
FOUNDER OF CitiKitty.
CitiKitty IS SEEKING $100,000
FOR 15% EQUITY IN OUR COMPANY.
FOR THE 200 MILLION CAT OWNERS
AROUND THE WORLD,
CLEANING A LITTER BOX IS
A CHORE THAT WE ALL DREAD.
LITTER BOXES...
ARE GERM BREEDING GROUNDS.
KITTY LITTER GETS TRACKED
EVERYWHERE,
THEY STINK UP OUR HOMES,
THEY COST LOTS OF MONEY
TO CONTINUALLY FILL,
AND THEY CAUSE FIGHTS
IN OTHERWISE
PEACEFUL HOUSEHOLDS,
BECAUSE NOBODY WANTS
TO CLEAN THIS THING.
IT'S DISGUSTING. AND CAT OWNERS
DON'T KNOW THERE'S ANY OPTION.
BUT THERE IS.
YOU CAN TOILET‐TRAIN YOUR CAT
WITH CitiKitty.
(O'Leary and Robert laugh)
TAKE A LOOK HERE.
(liquid trickling)
(sharks laughing)
WITH CitiKitty,
THE DIRTY LITTER BOX IS GONE,
YOUR HOME IS CLEANER,
YOU'RE SAVING MONEY,
YOU'RE DOING GOOD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT,
AND LIFE AT HOME IS BETTER
FOR YOU AND YOUR CAT.
CAN YOU GET IT AT ANY AGE?
IF IT'S AN OLD CAT,
DOESN'T WANT TO LEARN
NEW TRICKS?
OLD CATS CAN LEARN NEW TRICKS.
MY CAT WAS 11
WHEN I TOILET‐TRAINED HER.
I DID SOME RESEARCH‐‐
HOW DO YOU TOILET‐TRAIN A CAT?
IN A MATTER OF WEEKS,
SAMANTHA WAS USING THE TOILET,
THE LITTER BOX WAS GONE,
WE WERE SAVING MONEY. IT WORKS.
OKAY, WALK ME THROUGH
HOW YOU TRAINED SAMANTHA.
YOU SAID, "SAMANTHA, YOU CAN'T
POOP IN THE LITTER ANYMORE."
OKAY, SO THE REASON
A CAT USES A LITTER BOX
IS BECAUSE IT IS THE OPTION
WE GIVE THEM TO COVER THE S‐‐
THE SMELL OR THE SCENT
OF THEIR WASTE FROM PREDATORS.
TO AVOID BEING TORN TO SHREDS
BY A LARGER ANIMAL.
EXACTLY. SO WHEN
YOU TOILET‐TRAIN THEM,
WHEN YOU GET TO THE POINT WHERE
YOUR CAT IS ACTUALLY PERCHING
AND THEY'RE GOING THE BATHROOM
IN THE WATER OF THE TOI‐‐
THAT'S WHEN THEY REALIZE
THAT THE WATER OF THE TOILET
COVERS THE SCENT BETTER
THAN KITTY LITTER, AND IT'S JUST
A GRADUAL TRANSITION
FROM LITTER BOX TO TOILET.
YOU TAKE THE CitiKitty TRAINING
SEAT THAT YOU SEE THERE,
YOU PUT IN ON YOUR TOILET,
AND YOU FILL IT WITH
A SMALL AMOUNT OF KITTY LITTER.
YOU NEED A SPECIAL SEAT?
THAT'S WHAT CitiKitty IS.
SO THIS IS YOUR REGULAR TOILET.
YOU LIFT IT UP, TAKE IT OFF.
(Barbara) OH.
AFTER ONE WEEK,
YOU REMOVE THE FIRST RING
FROM THE TRAINING SEAT,
THAT'S IN ITS CENTER.
IT WILL MAKE A SMALL HOLE
IN THE TRAINING SEAT.
IT'S ABOUT THAT BIG.
YOUR CAT WILL CONTINUE
TO GO TO THE BATHROOM IN
THE LITTER OF THE TRAINING SEAT.
THE SAME THING AT RING TWO‐‐
YOU'RE MAKING THE HOLE LARGER.
AND AT THE THIRD RING,
THAT'S WHEN THEY'LL START
AIMING IN THE WATER
OF THE TOILET,
AND THAT'S WHEN THE CAT REALIZES
THE WATER OF THE TOILET
COVERS THE SCENT OF THE WASTE
BETTER THAN KITTY LITTER.
I'LL BET IT'LL BE GREAT
TO BE THERE FOR THAT.
THE CAT ACTUALLY LOOKS DOWN IN
THE BOWL AND SAYS, "OH, WATER."
YEAH.
"OH, I'M GOOD."
"I'M GOOD. I'M NOT GONNA BE
TORN TO SHREDS BY A PREDATOR."
YEAH. YEAH.
WHAT IF I HAVE TO GO
TO THE TOILET AFTER THE KITTY?
JUST LIFT THE TOILET SEAT UP,
TAKE IT OFF, AND SET IT ASIDE,
AND THEN YOU PUT IT BACK ON‐‐
DURING THE TRAINING.
THAT'S ONLY FOR A FEW WEEKS.
DURING THE TRAINING,
DO THEY MISS THE SEAT AT TIMES?
I'M NOT SURE I'D SHARE MY TOILET
WITH MY CAT.
YOU'RE SO SELFISH, BARBARA.
YEAH.
NO, NO. I JUST WONDER
IF THEY ARE ACCURATE.
THEY ARE VERY ACCURATE. PEOPLE
SAY, "OH, I DON'T WANT TO SHARE
MY TOILET SEAT WITH‐‐WITH
MY CAT." THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM.
OH, THAT'S DISGUSTING.
NO, WHAT'S DISGUSTING IS HAVING
YOUR CAT USE A LITTER BOX.
LET'S NOT FORGET
THIS IS A BOX OF POOP,
AND YOUR CAT IS GOING
TO THE BATHROOM IN THERE,
AND THEN THEY'RE WALKING
IN YOUR HOUSE,
THEY'RE WALKING ON YOUR SOFA,
YOUR KITCHEN COUNTER.
THIS IS SO CRAZY.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER‐‐
OKAY, IF YOU DON'T HAVE CATS,
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
(O'Leary and Barbara laugh)
NOW IS THERE ANY LIABILITY
IF SOMEBODY'S CAT DROWNS?
LIABILITY, DAYMOND?
IF SOMEBODY'S CAT DROWNS.
THEY'RE HOPPING UP
ON THE TOILET...
OH.
AND FALLS IN AND IS DEAD,
THEIR BELOVED‐‐
JUST GET A NEW CAT.
THEY'RE 15 BUCKS.
(Daymond) YEAH. (laughs)
THAT'S HORRIBLE.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT.
DOES THE CAT EVER FALL IN?
NO, IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
REBECCA,
WHAT DOES IT SELL FOR
AND WHAT'S IT COST
TO MAKE THIS PRODUCT?
THE RETAIL IS $29.99.
EACH COST PER UNIT IS $4.76.
I MANUFACTURE IN QUANTITIES
OF 10,000.
HOW MANY OF THESE
HAVE YOU SOLD ACTUALLY?
I HAVE SOLD 40,000 OF THESE
OFF MY WEB SITE ALONE.
THIS YEAR I'M DOING
$350,000 IN SALES.
LAST YEAR I DID $225,000.
I HAVE SOLD $1.4 MILLION
IN CAT TOILET‐TRAINING KITS,
AND I HAVE NEVER ADVERTISED.
I'VE BEEN ON
"GOOD MORNING AMERICA," CNN,
I'VE BEEN
IN "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
PEOPLE LOVE TALKING ABOUT IT.
IT'S GOT BROAD APPEAL.
HOW MUCH MONEY
HAVE YOU PUT UP SO FAR?
INITIALLY,
I INVESTED $20,000,
BUT CitiKitty IS
A CONSTANT INVESTMENT,
SO I'M CONSTANTLY PUTTING MONEY
BACK IN THE COMPANY
WHILE REMAINING PROFITABLE.
SO WHAT WILL YOU USE
THE MONEY FOR?
I WOULD USE THE MONEY TO HI‐‐UM,
TO GET SALES REPS FOR CitiKitty,
AND ALSO DO MARKETING.
I WANT TO TAKE CitiKitty
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
I BELIEVE THIS IS
A MULTIMILLION‐DOLLAR PRODUCT.
WELL, REBECCA,
I'LL TELL YOU WHERE I'M AT.
IT'S JUST NOT A BUSINESS
I HAVE, UH, ANY INTEREST IN
OR CAN ADD VALUE.
AND I DON'T HAVE A CAT.
I HAVE A DOG. UH, SO I'M OUT.
WELL, I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU.
REBECCA, I HATE CATS.
I HATE THEM.
BUT YOU LOVE MONEY, RIGHT?
I LOVE MONEY.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
OKAY.
BUT IF A CAT EVER
GAVE ME A PROBLEM,
AND I WAS IN A HIGH APARTMENT,
I WOULDN'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THAT CAT
FIVE MINUTES LATER. I'M OUT.
WHEW. TOUGH CROWD.
REBECCA,
I LOOK FOR TWO THINGS‐‐
I LOOK FOR A‐A PRODUCT
THAT SOLVES A PROBLEM
AND A MASS‐MARKET PRODUCT,
AND I THINK THIS MEETS
BOTH OF THOSE.
EVERY PET STORE IN AMERICA
WILL WANT THIS PRODUCT
IF YOU PUT THIS ON TV.
THAT'S WHAT I DO,
AND I'M INTERESTED
IN THIS DEAL.
SO I WOULD GIVE YOU
THE $100,000,
BUT I WOULD NEED
40% OF THE COMPANY.
UM, I'D LIKE TO HEAR
ALL THE OTHER OFFERS
BEFORE... COUNTERING.
WHO SAID
THERE'S ANY OTHER OFFERS?
UM, I WAS ON THE FENCE.
I THINK THAT THERE'S PROBABLY
A BETTER OFFER
WITH A BETTER STRATEGIC PARTNER,
SO I'M GONNA BE OUT.
OKAY.
REBECCA, I HAVE AN OFFER
ON THE TABLE.
LET'S GET
TO THE BOTTOM LINE HERE.
NO, WAIT JUST A MINUTE.
OBVIOUSLY KEVIN'S A GREAT GUY
TO PUT IT ON TV.
THE DOWNSIDE TO HIS OFFER IS,
IS IT COSTS
A LOT OF MONEY
TO MAKE A TV COMMERCIAL.
IT COSTS A LOT OF MONEY
TO BUY THE AIRTIME.
I DON'T THINK $100,000 IS
GONNA DO IT.
SO YOU REALLY NEED A PARTNER
IN THE TV BUSINESS,
AND MY PARTNER IN NEW YORK OWNS
THE BIGGEST TV BUSINESS
CALLED "AS SEEN ON TV,"
SO I'LL GIVE YOU THE $100,000
FOR ONLY THE 15% IF YOU'RE
WILLING TO TAKE THE CHANCE
THAT HE BUYS IN
ON PUTTING IT ON TV.
DID YOU CATCH
THAT SUBTLE NUANCE?
SHE'S SAYING
ONLY IF HER FRIEND LIKES IT
VERSUS HARRINGTON, WHO'S SAYING
HE WANTS TO DO A DEAL.
IT'S A RISK DEAL.
REBECCA, I AM THE TV EXPERT
IN THE PANEL HERE. OKAY?
YES.
SHE HAS TO GO TO SOMEBODY THAT
MAY LIKE IT, MAY NOT LIKE IT.
YOU'RE HERE TO DO A DEAL.
BUT LET‐‐WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
BUT LET ME ALSO SAY TO YOU,
I SUSPECT VERY MUCH
HE'LL LIKE IT,
BECAUSE THE ONLY CRITERIA HE HAS
IS PROVEN SALES.
WHAT A FASCINATING SITUATION‐‐
WITH CERTAINTY, YOU HAVE
TO GIVE UP 40% EQUITY
OR WITH THE RISK YOU'VE GOT,
YOU ONLY HAVE TO PAY 15% EQUITY.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
♪♪♪
REBECCA HAS TWO OFFERS
ON THE TABLE‐‐
KEVIN HARRINGTON HAS OFFERED
$100,000
FOR 40% OF HER BUSINESS,
WHILE BARBARA HAS OFFERED
THE SAME AMOUNT,
BUT FOR ONLY 15%.
HOWEVER, BARBARA'S OFFER
COMES WITH A CONDITION
THAT HER PARTNER IN NEW YORK
WILL ALSO WANT TO INVEST.
REBECCA,
I'M READY TO DO THIS DEAL.
I'M READY TO PRODUCE THE TV
COMMERCIAL, BUY THE MEDIA,
AND GET THIS INTO
EVERY PET STORE IN AMERICA.
I THINK YOU'RE HEARING
FROM BARBARA, SHE HAS TO GO
TO SOMEBODY WHO'S GONNA MAYBE
SAY YES AND MAYBE SAY NO.
YOU'RE HERE TO DO A DEAL TODAY.
I'M READY TO DO A DEAL.
I THINK YOU'RE A GREAT PARTNER
FOR THIS,
BUT AT 40% FOR $100,000,
I CAN'T DO IT.
IT'S NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST
FOR CitiKitty.
I MADE $100,000 LAST YEAR ALONE,
AND THAT PRODUCT WASN'T
EVEN IN RETAIL YET.
GIVE ME A COUNTEROFFER.
20% AT $100,000.
YOU ARE ONE SHREWD CAT.
$100,000, 25%.
THAT'S IT.
UM...
LET ME JUST REMIND YOU THAT
EVERY TIME I JUMPED INTO BED
WITH A GUY IN A BUSINESS DEAL,
IT WAS SWEET IN THE BEGINNING.
IT NEVER WOUND UP
IN A GOOD PLACE.
WHY DO YOU ALWAYS
BRING IT BACK TO SEX?
YOU USE SEX.
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU'D SAY THAT.
(Barbara) THIS ISN'T ABOUT SEX.
UM...
YOU WANT TO THINK ABOUT IT
AND COME BACK?
NO, NO, NO.
(Harrington) DON'T MAKE
THE WRONG MOVE.
NO, NO. NO, IF I WALK OUT HERE,
THERE'S DAGGERS IN MY BACK.
(Daymond) SHE MUST KNOW US.
IT'S TIME TO MAKE A DECISION.
IT'S JUST NOT... OH.
KEVIN, I KNOW THAT YOU ARE
THE GURU FOR AS SEEN ON TV,
BUT I LIKE BARBARA.
I LIKE THE FEMALE TOUCH.
(groans)
(speaks indistinctly) I'M
A FEMALE. LOOK AT ME. BIG SELL.
SHE'S TRYING TO PLAY IT UP.
SHE'S SO SEXIST.
BUT THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN
SOMETHING ABOUT BARBARA
THAT YOU CAN'T TURN AWAY FROM,
AND IT'S‐‐IT'S A HEART. I MEAN‐‐
YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S CALLED?
IT'S CALLED TRUST.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT.
OH, COME ON!
(Daymond and O'Leary groan)
LOOK, YOU KNOW, WE CAN'T SPEND
THE REST OF OUR LIVES HERE.
YOUR CAT'S GONNA BE DEAD
BY THE TIME YOU GET HOME.
I WOULD DO‐‐
I WOULD DO 20% AT $100,000.
I LOVE YOU, BARBARA,
BUT I WOULD DO THAT.
OH.
ALWAYS ABOUT MONEY.
DON'T DO IT, BECAUSE I'M GONNA
DROP THE CONTINGENCY,
JUST TO KNOCK HIM
OUT OF THE BOX.
(gasps) WHY?
YOU ARE A WITCH, BARBARA.
I'M NOT A WITCH.
CAN'T WE WORK TOGETHER?
I KNOW YOU GUYS HAVE
WORKED TOGETHER BEFORE.
CAN WE WORK TOGETHER? I‐I‐I...
I THINK WE STAND ALONE
ON THIS DEAL.
OHH!
(Daymond) OHH!
IF YOU DON'T MAKE A DECISION,
I'M TAKING A CONTRACT OUT
ON YOUR CAT. YOU GET HOME,
HE'LL BE MISSING.
YOU'VE GOT THE SOLID TV GUY
AND THE WITCH SNAKE.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A DECISION
TO BE MADE RIGHT HERE.
SO NOW I'M SAYING I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $100,000 FOR THE 15%
WITH NO CONTINGENCIES,
SO THE RISK OF ME PRODUCING IT
ON TV's ON MY SIDE.
DON'T YOU THINK I'M GONNA BE
MOTIVATED TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN?
I'VE MADE AN OFFER, REBECCA.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION
RIGHT NOW.
20%, $100,000.
YES.
OKAY.
CRAP!
(Daymond) AAH! (laughs)
(Robert) YEAH! VERY GOOD!
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
KEVIN. WHOO!
ONE FOR THE BOYS.
YEAH!
(O'Leary) REBECCA, WHAT HAPPENED
TO ALL THE LOVE?
I DO LOVE YOU, BARBARA!
BYE. AAH!
KEVIN, YOU'RE A DIRTY DOG.
(Robert)
DO YOU REALLY HAVE A CAT?
I LOVE CATS. I DON'T HAVE ONE.
I LOVE THEM, THOUGH. (laughs)
THEY MAKE MONEY, OKAY?
(Robert laughs)
WITHOUT "SHARK TANK,"
I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE.
I'D BE SELLING THEM
ONE AT A TIME, YOU KNOW,
ACROSS THE INTERNET. AND THIS IS
GONNA MAKE THE PRODUCT HUGE.
I FEEL IT IN MY BONES,
I FEEL IT IN MY SOUL
THAT THIS IS THE NEXT STEP
FOR THIS COMPANY.
♪♪♪
LAST SEASON, WE SAW JEFF COHEN
AND HIS SON JOSH
PASS ON $1 MILLION OFFER
FROM THE SHARKS
FOR THEIR VOYAGE‐AIR GUITAR.
I DON'T ACCEPT THE DEALS
ON THE TABLE.
I'M STUNNED OF YOUR GREED.
LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
♪♪♪
WHEN WE LEFT "SHARK TANK,"
PEOPLE THOUGHT WE WERE CRAZY
FOR TURNING DOWN $1 MILLION.
VOYAGE‐AIR GUITAR IS THE WORLD'S
FIRST FOLDABLE GUITAR.
EVEN THOUGH WE DIDN'T GET A DEAL
WITH THE SHARKS,
GOING ON "SHARK TANK" WAS
ONE OF THE BEST THINGS
THAT WE COULD'VE DONE
FOR THIS COMPANY.
IT VALIDATED THE PRODUCT,
GAVE US A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF EXPOSURE.
I PASSED ON THE DEAL
WITH THE SHARKS
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO LICENSE
THE PATENTED HINGE
TO OTHER GUITAR MANUFACTURERS
AND SIT BACK
AND COLLECT ROYALTIES. QUITE
FRANKLY, I WASN'T CONVINCED
THAT LICENSING IS THE RIGHT WAY
TO START THE COMPANY.
THE GUITARS ARE SELLING
INCREDIBLY WELL.
OUR SALES HAVE EXCEEDED
ONE AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS,
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOST LIKELY
DOUBLE THAT IN REVENUE
DURING 2011.
WE ALSO JUST CAME OUT
WITH ELECTRIC VOYAGE‐AIR,
WHICH IS SO POPULAR. IN FACT,
IT JUST BECAME SOLD OUT.
LOTS OF BIG CELEBRITIES USE
OUR VOYAGE‐AIR GUITAR.
BIG ARTISTS LIKE JOHN OATES
OF HALL & OATES, BRAD PAISLEY,
WILLIE NELSON, AND MANY OTHER
WELL‐KNOWN ARTISTS.
VOYAGE‐AIR GUITAR
WOULD NOT BE NEARLY
AS SUCCESSFUL AS IT IS TODAY
WITHOUT THE EXPOSURE
FROM "SHARK TANK."
♪♪♪
NEXT UP IS KIM PREIS,
WITH A T‐SHIRT COMPANY
ESPECIALLY DESIGNED
FOR EXPECTING MOMS.
MY NAME IS KIM PREIS,
MY COMPANY IS SAMSON MARTIN,
AND I AM SEEKING $50,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 15% EQUITY
IN MY BUSINESS.
A FEW YEARS AGO,
I CAME UP WITH THE IDEA
BECAUSE ALL OF MY GIRLFRIENDS
WERE PREGNANT AT THE TIME,
AND THE OBVIOUS QUESTION
THAT THEY'RE ASKED IS
WHEN ARE YOU DUE?
SO I THOUGHT, HOW LOGICAL IT
WOULD BE TO PUT IT ON A T‐SHIRT?
WE HAD LAUNCHED
WITH THE "DUE IN" TEE,
AND EXPANDED THE COLLECTION
TO VARIOUS OTHER EXECUTIONS.
I ORIGINALLY POSITIONED THE LINE
IN UPSCALE BOUTIQUES.
MY GOAL WAS REALLY TO ALIGN IT
WITH HIGHER‐END BRANDS,
BUT DUE TO THE RECESSION,
THE BOUTIQUE BUSINESS
HAS BEEN HIT TREMENDOUSLY HARD.
I NEED TO REPOSITION THE BRAND
AND REALLY COME UP WITH A WAY
TO PRODUCE
A MORE ECONOMICAL COLLECTION
AND TAKE IT TO MASS RETAILERS.
THIS IS A PROVEN WINNER.
I'VE DONE TREMENDOUS SALES.
I HAVE GOTTEN TREMENDOUS PRESS.
I JUST NEED THE CONTACTS,
THE DOORS TO BE OPEN,
THE PROPER FINANCIAL INJECTION
TO REPOSITION THE BRAND
AND GROW IT FURTHER.
LET'S START
WITH THE SALES NUMBERS.
(Robert) YEAH.
LAST YEAR I DID $90,000
IN SALES. I'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR 6 YEARS. I'VE DONE
A TOTAL OF $1.4 MILLION
OUT OF MY BASEMENT.
SO HAVE YOUR SALES GONE UP
AND THEN STARTED DROPPING?
YES.
SO WHAT WERE THE SALES
AT THEIR PEAK?
$400,000.
AND THEY DROPPED TO $90,000?
MM‐HMM.
HOW MUCH DO YOU SELL THESE FOR?
UH, THEY RANGE.
THE TANK TOPS ARE
ANYWHERE BETWEEN $38 AND $42.
THE LONG SLEEVES ARE
ANYWHERE BETWEEN $55 AND $60.
CAN YOU STOP ANYBODY ELSE
FROM PUTTING THIS ON A T‐SHIRT?
I HAVE A TRADEMARK ON "DUE IN."
THE WORDS "DUE IN"‐‐
NO ONE ELSE COULD USE?
"DUE"‐‐WHEN I LAUNCHED
THE LINE BACK IN '04,
I GOT TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
PRESS, CELEBRITY RECOGNITION.
JENNIFER GARNER, ANGELINA JOLIE,
BRITNEY SPEARS.
KIM, YOU'RE A T‐SHIRT COMPANY.
THE OBJECTIVE IS
TO SELL MORE T‐SHIRTS, MAKE MORE
MONEY. WE ALL AGREE ON THAT.
YEAH. RIGHT.
YOU HAVE PICKED A SUBSEGMENT
OF A SUBSEGMENT.
IN OTHER WORDS,
I CAN'T SELL TO MEN.
THAT'S 50% OF THE MARKET GONE...
SURE.
BUT I CAN'T SELL
TO ALL WOMEN EITHER.
I CAN ONLY SELL
TO THE PREGNANT ONES. THAT'S IT.
6 MILLION.
OKAY, BUT I'M SAYING
IT'S VERY HARD
TO GET TO MY TARGET MARKET
BECAUSE THEY TEND TO BE PREGNANT
FOR ONLY NINE MONTHS.
(Robert) I LIKE THAT APPROACH.
I LIKE THE FACT
THAT YOU FOUND
A VERY NICHE MARKET.
THE BEAUTY
OF THE MATERNITY MARKET IS
YOU HAVE A NEW CUSTOMER
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE.
WHEN YOU'RE PREGNANT,
YOUR OLD CLOTHES DON'T FIT.
YOU'RE A FORCED CUSTOMER.
YES.
MY ISSUE IS NOT THE MARKET.
MY ISSUE IS YOU WERE HOT
A FEW YEARS AGO.
YOU'RE SAYING
SHE'S NOT HOT NOW?
KEVIN, MY MIND IS NOT
IN THE GUTTER LIKE YOURS.
OH.
I'M SIMPLY TALKING ABOUT
HER BUSINESS.
SHE IS A BEAUTIFUL WOMAN,
OF COURSE,
IF THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE IMPLYING.
BUT YOU HIT SALES OF $400,000,
RECESSION HIT,
AND THEN YOU KIND OF HIT BOTTOM.
CAN YOU BE HOT TWICE?
CAN THAT BABY BE BORN AGAIN?
ABSOLUTELY.
I KNOW I CAN DO IT AGAIN
BECAUSE, I MEAN,
THIS IS‐‐THIS TOOK A GREAT DEAL
OF THOUGHT IN DEVELOPING.
A LOT OF THE MATERNITY T‐SHIRTS
OUT THERE‐‐
THEY'RE NOT FLATTERING
TO WOMEN.
THEY'RE NOT MAKING THEM
LOOK BEAUTIFUL AND SEXY.
WHEN I LAUNCHED THE LINE, IT WAS
ABOUT ESTABLISHING A BRAND AND‐‐
WELL, HOW DO YOU THINK
YOU'VE DONE THERE?
I'VE NEVER HEARD
OF SAMSON MARTIN.
WELL, YOU'RE NOT PREGNANT.
I KNOW, BUT THAT'S MY PROBLEM‐‐
I CAN ONLY SELL IT
TO PEOPLE THAT ARE PREGNANT.
(Barbara) YOU SAID
YOU WANTED REPOSITIONING.
THAT MEANS YOU WANT TO MAKE
A CHEAPER‐PRICED BRAND?
YES.
THEN LET'S SAY YOU DO.
THEN WHAT DO YOU DO WITH
THAT CHEAPER T‐SHIRT?
I TAKE IT
TO A LARGER RETAILER.
I CAN'T RELY ON
THESE SMALLER BOUTIQUES TO‐‐
FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH,
I CAN'T DO IT.
I'M THINKING TARGET.
I'M THINKING JCPenney,
I'M THINKING KOHL'S.
I'M THINKING buybuy BABY.
(Daymond) HAVE YOU TALKED
TO THEM?
I HAVE NOT.
(Robert) WHY?
I DON'T HAVE
THE PROPER CONTACTS.
YOU BUILT A BUSINESS.
YOU'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR ALL THIS TIME.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE PROPER...
YEAH.
YOU CAN'T PICK UP A PHONE
AND MAKE A CALL?
I HAVE MADE PHONE CALLS.
I HAVE NOT...
(Barbara) CONNECTED.
YOU WANT $50,000.
YES.
WHAT‐‐WHERE YOU GONNA GO
WITH THAT?
THE MONEY WOULD BE
FOR MARKETING, PRODUCTION,
MANUFACTURING, AND TO
ESSENTIALLY FILL THE ORDERS.
YOU WOULD BE SPENDING THE MONEY
ON DEVELOPING
THIS NEW PRODUCT LINE...
YES.
FROM‐‐FROM SCRATCH, REALLY.
YES. BUT IT‐‐
DAYMOND, YOU'RE A BRAND GUY.
HOW HARD OR EASY IS IT
TO TAKE A BRAND
THAT'S DECLINING
AND MAKE IT HOT AGAIN?
A LOT OF THE CUSTOMERS NOW ARE
NOT BUYING AS MANY CLOTHES.
THE WOMEN'S BUSINESS IS
INCREASINGLY HARD AT THE MOMENT.
AND GETTING TO THOSE GUYS
SHE'S ASKING ABOUT GETTING TO‐‐
EVERYBODY'S TRYING TO GET TO
THEM. I'M TALKING KNOWN BRANDS
THAT ARE DOING $4 BILLION
AND $5 BILLION.
THE BIG BRANDS THAT WE ALL KNOW
ARE TRYING TO GET SOME BECAUSE
THEY'RE STUCK ON INVENTORY
AND THEY HAVE TO OFFLOAD IT.
SO...
WELL, YOU'RE MR. POSITIVE.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE BRAND
HAS SUFFERED DUE TO THE FACT
THAT THE COMPANY'S
NOT HOT ITSELF.
THIS IS JUST THE ENVIRONMENT.
SO I WOULD HAVE TO SAY
THAT I'M OUT.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
MY THOUGHTS, TOO.
I DON'T LIKE
HOW MANY DIFFERENT SKEWS
YOU NEED TO CARRY IN INVENTORY.
YOU GOT MONTHS,
YOU'VE GOT VARIOUS COLORS.
YOU'VE GOT SIZES,
YOU GOT THIS, YOU GOT THAT.
I MEAN, YOU PROBABLY GOT 30
OR 40 DIFFERENT VERSIONS
OF THIS PRODUCT. THAT‐‐THAT'S
WHERE I'M COMING FROM.
OKAY.
IT'S‐‐IT'S TOO CONFUSING OF
A BUSINESS FOR ME, SO I‐I'M OUT.
KIM, THERE'S A LOT OF PREGNANT
WOMEN IN NEW YORK CITY,
WHERE I LIVE...
MM‐HMM.
RUNNING AROUND
IN PREGNANCY T‐SHIRTS.
MM‐HMM.
BUT THEY SIMPLY HAVE A MONTH.
IT DOESN'T SAY "DUE IN."
AND IN SOME WAYS, JUST SEEING
A "JANUARY" OR "MARCH,"
FOR ME, FEELS
A LITTLE BIT MORE CLEVER...
MM‐HMM.
THAN BEING SO LITERATE
AS "DUE IN MARCH."
YEAH, WELL,
THEY TOOK MY IDEA.
(chuckles) THEY DID.
I'M NOT SOLD IN THE VALUE
OF THE "DUE IN" PART OF IT,
SO I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW, KIM,
YOU'RE STARTING UPHILL AGAIN.
I'M NOT SURE I WANT TO BE THERE
TO, UH, FIGHT THAT BATTLE
WITH YOU. I'M OUT.
GIVE ME ONE REASON
THAT I SHOULD GIVE YOU $50,000.
BECAUSE I'VE DONE
$1.4 MILLION IN SALES
IN MY BASEMENT, ON MY OWN‐‐
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE
FOR ME LATELY?
WHO CARES ABOUT THE PAST?
WHAT ABOUT RIGHT NOW? IT‐‐
UH, I‐I BELIEVE
THAT THIS BRAND
AND THE ACTUAL PRODUCT IS
A WINNER.
I'M STUCK
ON THIS SUBSEGMENT PROBLEM
BECAUSE I CAN SELL T‐SHIRTS
TO 250 MILLION PEOPLE
OR 6 MILLION PEOPLE.
LET ME THINK ABOUT THAT.
RIGHT.
HMM. 250,000,000.
BUT‐‐
KIM, I GOTTA TELL YOU, THIS IS
THE T‐SHIRT DEAL FROM HELL.
YOU CAN'T SELL IT TO ANYBODY
EXCEPT PREGNANT WOMEN,
SALES ARE GOING DOWN,
THE MARKET'S GETTING SOFT,
PRICE POINTS ARE COMING DOWN.
I MEAN, I'M TRYING TO FIND
SOMETHING, ANYTHING.
BUT NO, IT'S ALL DEATH
AND DESTRUCTION IN YOUR STORY.
IT'S HORRIBLE. I'M OUT.
(Robert) WOW. THAT WAS...
WOW.
WOW. THAT'S HARSH.
WELL, AM I WRONG?
TALK ABOUT THROWING THE, UH,
BABY WITH THE BATHWATER.
HE'S NEGATIVE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DOUBT
I'M TELLING THE TRUTH?
I DON'T THINK I'M A, YOU KNOW,
A DEATH INVESTMENT.
BUT I‐I WOULD BE KILLING MONEY
IF I GAVE IT TO YOU.
I ONLY WORRY ABOUT THE DEATH
OF THE MONEY. THAT'S IT.
OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WHAT ARE YOU THANKING US FOR?
BECAUSE SHE'S POLITE.
THAT'S WHY.
BECAUSE I'M A LADY.
(Robert) THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU DON'T REALLY WANT TO THANK
ME FOR THAT INFORMATION, DO YOU?
NO, BUT WHAT‐‐
W‐WHY ARE YOU, UH...
I'M JUST TRYING TO BE HONEST.
THAT'S IT.
(Barbara) BUT SHE'S NOT ARGUING.
LEAVE HER ALONE.
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES THE TRUTH IS
THE BEST MEDICINE.
FINE, KEVIN. ENOUGH.
LET'S GO.
(Robert) SHE'S JUST BEING NICE.
SHE THANKED YOU
FOR LISTENING TO HER.
SHE WAS‐‐YOU DON'T WANT
TO HEAR THIS.
(Robert) I THINK IT'S VERY
PROFESSIONAL TO THANK SOMEBODY.
THANK YOU.
I HATE THE FACT
WE MAKE PEOPLE FEEL SO BAD.
(O'Leary) YOU KNOW, ROBERT,
WHAT'S DEPRESSING ABOUT YOU IS
YOU CAN'T DEAL WITH THE TRUTH,
BECAUSE THE MONEY
WILL NEVER LIE.
KEVIN‐‐
THAT MONEY IS TELLING ME
THAT THIS IS A LOSER.
KEVIN, YOU'RE NOT
GONNA BELIEVE THIS,
BUT THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE'S
TRUTHS THAN YOURS IN THE WORLD.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE.
THERE'S ONLY ONE TRUTH IN MAKING
MONEY‐‐YOU EITHER MAKE IT
OR YOU LOSE IT. THAT'S IT.
SHE'S LOSING IT.
(Barbara) OKAY, WE'RE DONE.
OKAY, TIME OUT, GUYS.
WE'VE BEEN HERE.
SHE MAY RECOVER.
LET'S GO. TIME OUT.
(sighs) I DEFINITELY BELIEVE
THAT...
COMING AT ME, TELLING ME
THAT MY BUSINESS IS DEAD
AND THAT THIS IS
INVESTMENT SUICIDE
WAS A LITTLE, UH...
IT WAS A LITTLE DISRESPECTFUL
AND A LITTLE UNNECESSARY.
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS ALDO ORTA.
I'M ORIGINALLY FROM MEXICO CITY.
IN THE PRESENT TIME,
I LIVE IN CHICAGO.
MY WHOLE LIFE,
I'VE BEEN AN ARTIST.
I LEFT HOME BECAUSE
I REALLY WANT TO PURSUE
MY LIFE AS AN ARTIST
AND THE FREEDOM
TO BE AN ARTIST IN AMERICA.
MY ARTWORK IS INSPIRED
FROM ALL CULTURES'
MYTHOLOGY AND HISTORY,
AND IT HAS A MESSAGE‐‐
TO USE THESE SYMBOLS
AS A REMINDER
OF APPRECIATION OF LIFE.
♪♪♪
I KNOW WITH THE HELP
OF THE SHARKS,
WE CAN CHANGE PEOPLE'S LIVES
WITH MY DESIGNS
AND I CAN MAKE
MY AMERICAN DREAM COME TRUE
AND INSPIRE
TO MANY OTHER PEOPLE, TOO.
♪♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ALDO ORTA.
I'M ASKING FOR $180,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 45% OF MY BUSINESS.
I AM THE CREATOR AND DESIGNER
FOR THIS BEAUTIFUL LINE
OF JEWELRY‐‐ALDO ORTA JEWELRY.
I AM HERE HERE BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN VERY EXCLUSIVE.
MOST OF MY CLIENTS
HAS BEEN VERY RICH PEOPLE,
ROYALTY, AND CELEBRITIES.
ROYALTY LIKE
THE ROYAL FAMILY OF KUWAIT,
THE ALGHANIM FAMILY,
THE BACARDI FAMILY.
ALSO I HAVE SO MANY CELEBRITIES,
LIKE CALVIN KLEIN,
CYNDI LAUPER, GRACE JONES,
BRIAN BOITANO, MARTHA WASH,
HOLLY HUNTER‐‐
AND I CAN GO ON AND ON.
I WANT TO DO THE SAME TYPE
OF MAJESTIC, GLAMOROUS,
BEAUTIFUL DESIGNS,
BUT MUCH MORE AFFORDABLE...
WHICH I AM VERY PROUD
TO PRESENT TO YOU.
I MADE THESE TWO DIFFERENT BOXES
FOR A VERY SPECIFIC REASON‐‐
BECAUSE THIS ONE IS
THE REAL THING‐‐
YOU CAN SEE
ALL MY HIGH‐END PIECES‐‐
AND THIS ONE IS
EXACTLY THE SAME QUALITY
WHEN IT COMES TO THE DETAIL,
BUT MUCH MORE AFFORDABLE, WHICH
I WANT FOR THE MASS MARKET.
IS THAT A BELT BUCKLE?
IT'S A BELT BUCKET, YEAH.
IT'S ALEXANDER THE GREAT.
DO I LOOK LIKE ROYALTY? YEAH.
OFF WITH YOUR HEAD.
ALDO, CAN YOU TELL ME A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT YOUR CREATIVE DESIGN?
IS IT RELIGIOUS? IS IT SEXUAL?
(Barbara and Harrington laugh)
WHAT'S THE INSPIRATION?
THE INSPIRATION IS HISTORY
AND MYTHOLOGY
FROM ALL CULTURES.
IT'S NOT A CERTAIN RELIGION...
NO, NO. IT'S TO UNIFY
ALL PEOPLE'S FAITH AND BELIEF,
AND I USE
THE MOST ICONIC SYMBOLS
AS A MESSAGE FOR AWARENESS.
DO YOU DO ALL THIS YOURSELF?
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER DESIGNERS?
I DO EVERYTHING.
THIS IS ALL MY DESIGNS.
WHAT HAPPENS, ALDO,
IF YOU WALK OUT OF HERE
AND A BUS RUNS YOU OVER?
WHAT DO YOU MEAN,
WHAT HAPPENS IF...
THE BUSINESS GOES, CORRECT?
I‐I'M‐‐IS‐‐I'M ONE‐MAN SHOW.
CORRECT.
ALDO, HOW MUCH IS THIS PIECE?
THAT PIECE IS SILVER WITH ENAMEL
AND GOLD PLATE.
$220.
THIS HAS GOT TO BE PRICED
UNDER $200, I THINK.
CAN YOU DESIGN A LINE
THAT'S UNDER $200?
I HAVE MANY OTHER PIECES HERE
WHERE THEY ARE UNDER $200.
BUT, ALDO, WILL PEOPLE
THAT ARE MAINSTREAM AMERICA
WANT SUCH EXTRAVAGANT JEWELRY
THAT ONLY THE RICH
AND THE ROYAL BUY?
IS THIS MAINSTREAM ENOUGH
THAT MRS. LOBINSKY
IN DES MOINES WANTS IT?
LISTEN, LOOK, ALDO,
WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE THAT NOBODY'S
BUYING JEWELRY RIGHT NOW.
HAVE YOU TALKED TO ANY,
UH, SHOPPING CHANNELS?
ACTUALLY, I WENT
BACK AND FORTH WITH QVC.
THEY LOVED MY JEWELRY.
THEY THINK IT'S A GREAT MARKET.
THEY WANT ME TO COME WITH
$50,000 FOR THE FIRST ORDER.
(Barbara) IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
USING THE MONEY FOR?
YEAH, EXACTLY.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
RIGHT NOW, THE CHALLENGE
I SEE IS YOU'RE‐‐YOU'RE MAKING
VERY EXPENSIVE ONE‐OFF PIECES
OF JEWELRY.
YOU'RE NOW GONNA GO
INTO THE MASS MARKET,
BUT YOU'RE NOT EXPERIENCED
IN THAT MASS‐MARKET FORMAT.
I'M ON THE FENCE RIGHT NOW.
ALDO, I THINK IT'S UNIQUE.
IT'S INTERESTING.
THE HISTORY PIECE IS WONDERFUL,
BUT I'M STUCK ON THIS PROBLEM.
IF YOU DO GET RUN OVER BY A BUS,
YOU'RE ROAD PIZZA.
I'M AN INVESTOR. I HAVE NOTHING.
I'VE GOT THE HISTORY,
YOUR MEMORIES,
I CAN VISIT YOUR GRAVE,
BUT MY MONEY'S DEAD, TOO.
YOU CAN GET RUN BY THE BUS,
AND WHAT HAPPENS TO YOUR FAMILY?
MY FAMILY'S GONNA BE HAPPY,
PARTICULARLY MY KIDS.
(Harrington and Barbara laugh)
AND THEN I HAVE TO BASICALLY
INSURE YOUR LIFE
FOR THE VALUE OF THE INVESTMENT,
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY,
YOU ARE IT. YOU'RE THE GUY.
THAT'S ALWAYS THE PROBLEM.
YOU'RE LIKE A PICASSO.
AND LOOK AT PICASSO,
WHERE THEY ARE.
YEAH, BUT HE'S BETTER DEAD.
I'M WONDERING,
IF YOU'RE DEAD, IS IT BETTER?
YOU WANT TO KILL ME.
(chuckles) YOU GUYS
ARE WITNESS, OKAY?
IS THE COLLECTION WORTH MORE
IF ALDO'S ROAD PIZZA?
(chuckles)
ALDO, LOVED YOUR PRESENTATION,
BUT WHEN THAT BUS MEETS YOU,
IT'S GONNA BREAK MY HEART.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
ALDO.
YOU KNOW, I‐I HAVE
A LITTLE KNOWLEDGE IN THIS,
AND I‐I HAVE TO SAY THIS STUFF
IS BEAUTIFUL,
BUT AT THE MOMENT,
WE'RE GOING THROUGH A STAGE
WHERE PEOPLE CAN'T PAY
THEIR MORTGAGES
AND THEY'RE DEFINITELY NOT
PAYING FOR JEWELRY.
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY
THAT I'M OUT.
ALDO, I LOVE YOUR WHOLE LOOK,
I LOVE THE JEWELRY,
BUT FOR A LARGE‐SCALE,
MIDDLE AMERICA MARKET,
I STILL THINK THE PRICE POINT'S
TOO HIGH. I'M OUT.
AND I'D LIKE TO SAY, UM,
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THIS
VERY MUCH‐‐
I THINK YOU LOOK THE PART.
THERE'S SOMETHING REALLY EERIE
ABOUT WATCHING YOU.
MEANT AS A COMPLIMENT. AND I
CAN'T TAKE MY EYES OFF OF YOU.
MY PASSION.
IT'S BEYOND YOUR PASSION.
YOU JUST LOOK THE PART.
BARBARA, GET A ROOM.
ALL RIGHT.
BARBARA,
DO YOU WANT TO DATE HIM?
(O'Leary and Barbara laugh)
SHE'S GETTING AROUND
TO THE OFFER.
WITH THE CAVEAT
THAT QVC REALLY DOES BUY IN,
I'LL GIVE YOU HALF THE MONEY,
BUT YOU'VE GOTTA GET THE OTHER
HALF FROM SOMEBODY ELSE.
YOUR OFFER FROM QVC‐‐
IS THAT A FIRM OFFER?
YES.
I'LL SAY THIS.
I'M‐‐I'M A VENDOR TO QVC,
SO I‐I KNOW THE TERMS
AND CONDITIONS.
YOU KNOW EXACTLY.
AND I HAVE ALL THE INSURANCE
AND EVERYTHING ALREADY IN PLACE,
SO, UM, NOW I'M ON THE FENCE.
ARE YOU GONNA BE ABLE TO USE
THE TRACK RECORD
OF THE‐‐OF THE KUWAIT PIECE
AND THE MONACO PIECE?
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THAT?
ABSOLUTELY.
THEY'RE MY FRIENDS.
GET OFF THE FENCE, KEVIN.
I'M IN FOR $90,000.
YEAH! (laughs)
I GET THE BELT BUCKLE, THOUGH.
I'M BUYING THE BELT BUCKLE.
(Barbara) DON'T GIVE HIM
THE BELT BUCKLE.
FORGET ALL THAT.
BEFORE YOU GET HIT BY A BUS,
GIVE ME THAT BELT BUCKLE.
DON'T GIVE IT TO HIM. HE DIDN'T
GIVE YOU ANY CASH. GET IT BACK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALDO, GET YOUR RING
FROM O'LEARY.
(O'Leary laughs)
YEAH!
THIS IS A ONE‐MAN SHOP.
LIKE, IT'S ONE GUY.
WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THE BUS HITS HIM?
YEAH, BUT THAT'S A NEGATIVE WAY
OF LOOKING AT IT.
NO, IT ISN'T.
IT'S A REALISTIC WAY.
FOR BARBARA AND KEVIN,
THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR UNDERSTANDING
AND APPRECIATION
ON MY BEAUTIFUL DESIGNS
AND THE MEANING BEHIND
AND MY PASSION AS AN ARTIST.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, SHARKS.
♪♪♪
NEXT UP IS
DOMINIQUE McCLAIN BARTEET
WITH AN INNOVATIVE TWIST
TO A PRODUCT BELOVED BY WOMEN
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
HELLO. MY NAME IS
DOMINIQUE McCLAIN BARTEET,
AND MY COMPANY IS ONESOLE.
I'M SEEKING $500,000
FOR 20% EQUITY OF MY COMPANY.
I LOVE SHOES,
AND ONE DAY I WENT TO THE MALL,
AND I BOUGHT A PAIR OF SHOES
AND I BOUGHT IT
IN THREE DIFFERENT COLORS.
I WENT HOME AND I WENT AHA‐‐
WOULDN'T IT BE EASIER
TO CHANGE THE TOP ON THE SHOE
BECAUSE THE BOTTOMS ARE
ALL THE SAME?
SO I SET OUT TO CREATE THIS IDEA
AND I DID. IT'S ONESOLE,
AND IT'S THE ORIGINAL
INTERCHANGEABLE SHOE.
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU HOW IT WORKS
BECAUSE IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
YOU CAN QUICKLY AND EASILY
GO FROM ONE LOOK TO ANOTHER
JUST LIKE THAT, IN SECONDS.
WE MADE IT
WHERE ANYBODY CAN DO IT.
YOU CAN EVEN CHANGE
THE STYLE OF THE TOP.
YOU CAN HAVE A CASUAL ONE
LIKE THIS, OR YOU CAN EVEN GO
TO A DRESSY STRAPPY
OR A SLING‐BACK OR EVEN A CLOG.
I MEAN, IT'S CRAZY HOW MANY
DIFFERENT LOOKS YOU CAN GET
IN A SINGLE SHOE.
AND ALSO, THIS SHOE HELPED ME
WITH ANOTHER PROBLEM I HAD.
I TRAVELED A LOT,
AND I WOULD HAVE
A WHOLE SUITCASE OF JUST SHOES.
SO NOW I DON'T EVEN PACK SHOES.
I WEAR MY ONESOLES,
PACK A HANDFUL OF TOPS.
I'VE SAVED SPACE
AND LUG‐‐LUGGAGE FEES.
IT'S THE PERFECT TRAVEL SHOE.
ALSO, WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF TOPS
TO CHOOSE FROM.
I MEAN, THE POSSIBILITIES
ARE ENDLESS.
AND I'D LIKE
IF BARBARA WOULD TRY THIS,
BECAUSE OUR BEST FEATURE
IS COMFORT.
PERFECT TIMING.
MY FEET ARE KILLING ME.
I'D LOVE TO.
IT'S 'CAUSE
YOU DON'T HAVE ONESOLES ON.
UM, WHAT'S THE RETAIL SELLING
PRICE OF‐‐OF THE SHOE?
THE RETAIL FOR THE SHOE
AND A SOLID TOP IS $70 TO $85.
AND THEN TOPS ARE SEPARATE,
OF COURSE,
AND THEY RANGE
FROM $12 TO $30.
COMFORTABLE?
THEY'RE HEAVEN.
(chuckles)
CAN I KEEP THEM
FOR THE REST OF THE DAY?
YES. YOU CAN HAVE THEM.
THANK YOU.
(Robert) HOW DO THEY FEEL?
(Barbara) LOVELY.
FEEL GOOD?
OH, MY GOD. NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
ONCE PEOPLE TRY IT ON,
THEY BUY IT.
DOMINIQUE, INTERESTING STORY.
UM, YOU HAVE A VALUE ON
THIS BUSINESS OF $2.5 MILLION.
(Robert) BUT SHE HAS SALES,
KEVIN.
WHAT ARE THEY?
I THINK MY COMPANY'S WORTH
MORE THAN THAT ACTUALLY.
I HAVE SALES‐‐
OF COURSE IT IS,
BUT WHY DON'T YOU HUMOR ME?
I'M GONNA SURPRISE YOU.
READY?
YEAH.
I HAVE GROSSED OVER $20 MILLION
IN THE LAST 4 YEARS.
I'M IN 2,000 STORES
IN OVER 30 COUNTRIES.
I'VE BEEN ON SEVERAL
TV SHOPPING CHANNEL NETWORKS
AND BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL.
WHAT ARE SALES LAST YEAR?
LAST YEAR WAS LOW.
IT WAS $3.5 MILLION.
I WAS $6 MILLION
THE YEAR BEFORE THAT.
WHERE DO YOU MAKE THIS?
IN CHINA?
NO. WE MAKE THE MOLDS IN ITALY
FOR THE SHOES, AND THEN I MAKE
THE TOPS, ACTUALLY,
IN PALM BEACH, FLORIDA.
CAN'T YOU SAVE MONEY
MAKING IT OFFSHORE?
THAT'S WHY I WANT
TO GET AN INVESTOR
BECAUSE I'M NOT A GOOD SOURCER,
AND I WOULD LIKE‐‐
I HAVE OTHER DESIGNS
FOR MORE COMPLICATED TOPS
THAT I CANNOT POSSIBLY MAKE
IN PALM BEACH,
I MEAN, AND HAVE A GOOD MARGIN.
BUT I'M NOT GOOD AT SOURCING.
WHAT'S THE STATUS OF THE‐‐
THE HOME SHOPPING BUSINESS
AND, UM, ARE YOU
ON THERE CURRENTLY OR‐‐
UH, I'VE BEEN ON QVC SIX TIMES.
I HAVE DONE NO ADVERTISING
OR MARKETING.
HOW HAVE YOU BEEN FINANCING
THIS BUSINESS?
WELL,
I'M REALLY A PHARMACIST.
I GOT‐‐I DID THIS AS A HOBBY
IN THE BACK OF MY PHARMACY.
AND I GOT SO BUSY,
AND IT BLEW UP, LIKE,
PROBABLY THE SECOND YEAR I DID
IT, THAT I MOVED MY PHARMACY
INTO THE SHOE FACTORY.
WOW. YOU'RE GONNA DO WHAT
IN SALES THIS YEAR?
UM, I'M OVER $4 MILLION,
SO I'M NOT SURE.
AND I'M‐‐I'M GOING OVERSEAS
A LOT THIS YEAR.
SO I JUST STARTED BRANCHING OUT
INTERNATIONALLY.
AND YOU'RE STILL ACTING
AS A PHARMACIST?
YES, SIR. I FILL PRESCRIPTIONS
AND FILL SHOE ORDERS, TOO.
(laughs)
(Robert) DO YOU MAKE ANY MONEY
ON YOUR SALES?
I MAKE 30% AVERAGE.
PROFITS LAST YEAR
WERE A MILLION DOLLARS?
OVER A MILLION DOLLARS, YEAH.
WHY DO YOU NEED THE MONEY? UM...
WELL, BARBARA
SHOULD UNDERSTAND THIS.
I, UM, DID A REAL ESTATE
INVESTMENT, LIKE THREE YEARS AGO
IN PALM BEACH, AND IT TIED UP
A LOT OF MY CAPITAL.
DON'T TELL ME
YOU BOUGHT A HOUSE.
I BOUGHT A HOUSE ON THE WATER
THERE AND, UM, NOW NOBODY'S‐‐
OUCH.
YEAH.
WHAT DOES IT COST TO MAKE THEM
AND WHAT DO YOU SELL THEM FOR?
AND THEN HOW DO YOU SELL THEM?
THE SOLE...
DIFFERENT STORES
BUY DIFFERENT WAYS.
LIKE, THE DEPARTMENT STORE
DID, LIKE, A TRAVEL KIT.
I HAVE A BAG THAT HAS
THREE SHOES IN ONE,
SO IT'S, LIKE,
A PACKAGE WITH THREE SHOES.
AND HOW MUCH DOES THAT COST
TO MAKE?
THAT COSTS, UM,
$18 FOR‐‐FOR THE 3 TOPS
AND THE PAIR OF SHOES
AND THE BAG.
AND THEN HOW MUCH
DO YOU SELL IT TO THE STORE FOR?
$35.
AND HOW MUCH DOES
THE STORE SELL IT FOR?
$85, $95‐‐AROUND THERE.
IT'S ALL PATENTED.
NOBODY CAN COPY THIS?
I HAVE TWO UTILITY PATENTS
AND TWO DESIGN PATENTS
THAT ARE ISSUED AND I HAVE
MORE THAT ARE PENDING.
AND THEN I'M TRADEMARKED
AND COPYRIGHTED IN 98 COUNTRIES.
WHAT'S YOUR BIGGEST ACCOUNT
OR THE BIGGEST COMPANY
INTERESTED IN YOUR BRAND?
UM, WELL, THIS COMPANY IN JAPAN,
THEY WANT 10,000 PAIR
AND, LIKE, 30,000 TOPS
OF THAT.
THAT'S, LIKE,
A HALF‐A‐MILLION‐DOLLAR ORDER.
(Daymond) WHAT ABOUT
DOMESTICALLY?
JCPenney, SO...
OH, WOW.
I'M REALLY STRUGGLING HERE
BECAUSE THIS IS A REAL BUSINESS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT SOMETIMES.
YEAH, SO IT'S ABOUT
A LACK OF CONFIDENCE
OF DOING IT ON YOUR OWN.
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR A PARTNER.
YEAH. I'M IN ABOVE MY HEAD,
I THINK.
WHY DO YOU SAY YOU'RE IN OVER
YOUR HEAD. YOU SAID THAT‐‐
'CAUSE I'M A PHARMACIST.
I'VE NEVER HAD A BUSINESS CLASS.
I'VE NEVER HAD
A SHOE DESIGN CLASS. I MEAN...
WHY ARE YOU
SELLING YOURSELF SHORT?
DO YOU REALIZE
HOW FEW BUSINESSES WE'VE HAD
COME OUT HERE AND GET
TO YOUR DEGREE OF SALES?
AND THEY'RE ALL OVERCONFIDENT.
(chuckles) I'M ALWAYS‐‐
I'M LIKE A LITTLE TURTLE
THAT GOES AND TAKES BABY STEPS.
AND I JUST WANT TO WIN.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE I'M DOING
EVERYTHING PROPERLY.
THAT'S WHY I DON'T‐‐
I DON'T TAKE THAT BIG JUMP,
BUT NOW I'M READY TO GO
TO THE NEXT LEVEL
AND JUST RAMP IT UP.
DOMINIQUE, IF I WERE TO PUT
THE HALF A MILLION DOLLARS UP,
WHAT WOULD YOU USE IT FOR?
WELL, WOULD BE MAKE SURE
I COULD FILL THESE BIG ORDERS
THAT ARE FIXING TO COME IN.
THEY'RE GOING CRAZY
IN SWITZERLAND
OVER MY SHOES RIGHT NOW.
I MEAN, I HAVE PEOPLE FIGHTING
OVER ME IN SAUDI ARABIA.
I HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
DISTRIBUTORS IN AUSTRALIA
AND NEW ZEALAND GOING CRAZY.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST THIS YEAR
IT WENT INTERNATIONAL, AND IT'S
JUST REALLY OVERWHELMING.
WHAT A FASCINATING STORY. WOULD
YOU SELL THE WHOLE BUSINESS?
I DON'T KNOW IF I'D WANT
TO DO THAT. (chuckles)
ALL RIGHT, I'LL GIVE YOU
$100,000 FOR 10%,
BUT...
GET THE OTHER FOUR GUYS IN.
AND WE'RE IN 50/50,
AND YOU GET THE $500,000.
♪♪♪
I'LL GIVE YOU $100,000 FOR 10%,
BUT...
GET THE OTHER FOUR GUYS IN,
AND WE'RE IN 50/50,
AND YOU GET THE $500,000.
I LIKE THIS PRODUCT.
I LIKE THE‐‐I LIKE THE DEAL.
SO MAKE AN OFFER, HARRINGTON.
I MEAN, I'M JUST‐‐I'M‐‐
I'M THINKING THAT VALUATION
OF A HALF A MILLION
FOR HALF THE COMPANY, THOUGH.
I BELIEVE IN THE PRODUCT,
BUT I DON'T NEED
ANY PARTNERS IN THIS.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE HALF A MILLION
FOR 35%.
DAYMOND,
THAT'S A GENEROUS OFFER.
IT'S A GREAT BUSINESS.
YOU KNOW, DAYMOND DOESN'T WANT
ANY PARTNERS, NO PARTNERS.
UM...
SO...
(mutters under breath)
I LIKE YOU GUYS.
I'LL SEND ALL YOUR WIVES SHOES.
EXCEPT FOR MY PARTNER,
SHE HAS CONTROLLING,
BUT I DON'T THINK
I NEED ANYBODY ON THIS ONE.
BARBARA, ARE YOU IN
OR ARE YOU OUT?
YOU KNOW, I LIKE YOU,
BUT IT'S JUST GONNA TAKE TOO
MUCH OF MY TIME, SO I'M OUT.
I'LL LEAVE AN OFFER FOR YOU
HERE, JUST TO GET IN THE MIX.
(clicks tongue)
I'LL GIVE YOU $500,000...
FOR 51%.
I'M NOT GONNA DO THAT.
THINK ABOUT IT FOR A SECOND.
SHE DID.
(Robert) WHY WOULD YOU MAKE
A WORSE OFFER?
YOUR OFFER IS INSULTING TO HER.
NO. NO, IT ISN'T.
HEAR ME OUT.
YOU READY? I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
$500,000 FOR 51%.
I'M GONNA HIRE A BANKER
TO SELL THIS COMPANY.
THE BUYER'S GONNA FIRE YOU
AFTER YOU'RE FILTHY RICH.
MM...
I TOLD YOU
I'M NOT TRUSTING. (chuckles)
ROBERT, $250,000 APIECE.
I WAS GOOD WITH THAT, BUT...
$250,000 A PIECE FOR 50%.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
DAYMOND,
I ACCEPT YOUR OFFER.
(Robert) WELL DONE.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD.
I AM, TOO.
DOMINIQUE, GREAT JOB.
CONGRATULATIONS.
I'M GONNA WEAR THOSE HOME.
I DO HAVE YOUR SIZE, TOO.
VERY GENEROUS OFFER, DAYMOND.
MY DEAL WAS STILL THE BEST.
I MADE THE OFFER
BECAUSE I LIKE TO WIN,
AND THAT IS A WIN.
THAT IS A WIN.
I JUST GOT HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS FROM DAYMOND.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT,
AND FOR THE‐‐
A LESS PERCENTAGE
THAN I COULD IMAGINE.
I MEAN, 35%‐‐I REALLY THOUGHT
HE WOULD'VE TAKEN ME TO 50%
OR‐‐OR TRIED FOR MORE.
I MEAN, I AM JUST ECSTATIC
RIGHT NOW.
I JUST CAN'T BELIEVE IT STILL.